suffice it to say part of what makes
simple such a singularity is the fact
that there isn't just a one in his name
but
one in the game
simple 1v3 in the bomb ticking this is
his environment this is his dream
anything to build his mental image as to
where they advance from looking for
another chance he just doesn't miss
ammonite through the doors closing the
gap is nexa dancing with him and it just
looks so good simple just the no scope
to collect six some say he was born to
play counter-strike others that he just
lives and breathes it whatever the
source of his godhood may be the
overwhelming consensus is that he is
undoubtedly a
once-in-a-generation player the kind who
quite simply
cannot be duplicated simple i swear if
you do anything ridiculous now i am
going to
there it is just
ridiculous no absolutely not he made me
sound like a gorilla why is simple so
good my answer is i don't know
thank you for that
i'm cheating cheating
but what if i told you that simple not
only could be cloned but already has
been
why he's repeating he's gonna die
[Music]
today i'm here to introduce you all to
ilya manasi ozipov a 16 year old cs go
prodigy from the cis who's spent the
past two years turning fpl into his own
personal playground
smoking the pack of nearly every
professional player to stumble into his
sandbox
of course what really stands out about
our boy is the uncanny resemblance he
bears to his game's goat he's a blonde
slavic wonder boy who plays for navi and
not only bangs with every boom stick on
the buy menu
but boasts game sense and gun skill
beyond his years
[Music]
this little tyke doesn't just walk and
talk like sasha the smasher
he frags like him too starting strong
were you ever going to be surprised by
that statement no and you should agree
no not again
chill leave them alone this isn't an orp
you can't keep it up with the rifle as
well you can't do it all save some for
your team i think he's the next simple
i'm pretty sure
though his reaction speed mixed with his
work ethic mixed with his genetics mixed
with his beautiful little haircut
everything about him just a little
legend didn't he man he's 16 and he
literally just it puts it on people's
head tops and servers but it's so crazy
the day that we get to see this guy
in like a in in a in a large-scale t1
event that's the
yeah that's the day the question is
what what'll happen if and when that day
ever comes
[Music]
so how is it that the cis managed to
produce a second simple in what ways is
he following in the footsteps of the
first and what might it spell for the
future of one of counter-strike's oldest
most storied organizations
[ __ ]
clip that
and post that don't read it
[Music]
okay so before manasi absolutely shits
on us through a window smoke let's take
a second to like the video subscribe to
the channel and yes for the millionth
time
turn on notifications i'm tired of this
grandpa that's too damn mad
okay so it's pretty much no exaggeration
at all to say that munici's been
cracking skulls since he was knee-high
to a p250 he started playing video games
around the age of six and was introduced
to counter-strike shortly thereafter by
you guessed it his big brother
[Music]
suffice it to say
caught on to the intricacies of cs
pretty [ __ ] quickly by 10 money had
reached a global elite by 12 he'd hit
level 10 on face it and in addition to
racking up thousands of hours in dota 2
was devoting nearly every waking second
of his life to cs go
um
had cemented himself as a freaking
terror it wasn't just that he was filthy
it was that he was a literal
fetus who was both farming and out
fragging everything in sight
by the end of 2019 monastery had
accumulated just under 4 000 elo on face
it was competing in amateur events and
had started to catch the attention of
some of the cis's biggest content
creators it was then that people began
drawing comparisons between our boy and
you know who is
it wasn't long
before had slipped onto the radar of
navi who'd just initiated an esports
summer camp program to round out their
newly announced academy roster navi
junior
[Music]
what's crazy is that monastery wasn't
even a part of that camp and was like
three years younger than anyone who was
and the fact that this fabled org was
prioritizing the signing of a relatively
unknown kid over prospects selected
specifically for the camp did lead to
some backlash from navi's notoriously
feral fanbase
as soon as word got out that navi had
somehow stumbled upon a second simple
everyone started tuning into munici's
stream to see what all the fuss was
about was this kid's resemblance to
sasha in the server just as uncanny as
it was outside of it
spoiler
yes
[Music]
but it was in march of 2020 that
monastery truly announced himself to the
cs world when a certain clip of him
dumpstering fools in the face it pro
league qualifier went viral needless to
say he made the cut and was invited to
join fpl at the age of 14 from his looks
to his frags to yes even his bands there
was no denying it manassee was basically
baby simple it was as if navi had given
their star fragger his very own mini me
figuring that it would take a pint-sized
clone to keep up with the goat's
impossible antics but it wasn't just
munici's generational talent that made
him reminiscent of csgo's so-called
smasher
it was his energy like simple this kid
bled counter-strike he played it with
every ounce of his being
but
like simple
he could also get a little
let's say
over invested i cannot be ready
for you flashing
i think he was under
[Music]
still regardless of his penchant for the
dark arts there was no denying munici's
inhuman abilities for the better part of
a year he [ __ ] on nearly every
competitor fpl had to offer
okay
i only seen connector in connector
king
monasteries remember when he didn't use
the op always and i remember i played
the first practice against him when he
started opening again he was mirage and
he literally dropped like 48 on me to
practice and i was just sat there like
this guy doesn't even have a passport
probably like i didn't get a passport
until i was 17. like this guy is [ __ ]
awesome but like he doesn't he's never
even thought about driving a car he's
never done he's probably never drunk
alcohol and he's literally just [ __ ]
wrecking me like what have i done wrong
in my life i can't even give him any
advice he's [ __ ] better than him
by 2021 it was clear this kid could very
well be the future of navi's
counter-strike roster he'd even managed
to wow simple from time to time
now as excited as everyone was about
manasi there was still one major problem
he was literally too young to compete
for navi's main lineup even at 16 he
couldn't make the age cut off for a lot
of cs go's tier 1 tournaments meaning
that all the community could do was wait
and watch
as he all but smurfed in season 1 of the
we play academy league one of his like
first kind of
mentors in the cis oh my god modesty
that is
just craziness
we're just gonna wait we're just gonna
let this play out because right now
everyone's fighting at top ramp but
modesty just keeps going back i mean
look at this do you have eyes
this is unbelievable this is like 10
years old man this is crazy
16 years old
and uh people are like oh these teams
are dog it's like dude he went 30 and
five man the question was
what would happen when munici was old
enough to play for navi's main lineup
with he simple and electronic standing
side by side would the rest of
professional counter-strike even stand a
chance would they just cower in fear
if you ever let
monetizing simple in the same team you
need to call el serbian to cancel the
game
just cancel the game or just say you'll
give them points and cancel this we
don't want to fight what i will say is
that in esports rambunctious rookies and
promising prodigies have been known to
come and go but true phenoms the likes
of which munici has undoubtedly proven
himself to be
are not an everyday occurrence whether
you're picking your jaw off the floor
looking at his stats or having your
perception of reality destroyed while
watching his stream
it is extremely obvious that this kid is
going to be huge he's streaming
constantly to 5 000 russians that just
deem him as the next god and i think
he's gonna have a long career in esports
as for how huge
we'll just have to wait and see but if
his progenitor is any indication of the
super stardom that seemingly awaits our
sweet little simple-to-be munici might
not only become a household name but a
hallowed one
that's the real grandpa meme you know
nacs just being like i'm tired of this
grandpa can liquid just win or lose
cleanly please my heart my heart
can't do it anymore i love watching you
more than anything but this ride i can't
i can't do this anymore i just can't
please stop shaving the ears off my life
please